this first way to
navigate hard times is to really
gather perspective to really ask
yourself
you know to go up to your mountaintop
and then look look across
now the solution to a negative thought
or emotion is not to ignore them
but to meet them with the active
engagement
of the truth a lot of people tell the
story that
everybody else wants them to tell want
to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and if you're
going through something difficult right
now
this video will help
seek perspective the first way for you
to
get through a hard time is seek
perspective here's a question i want to
ask you
when you're going through a hard time do
you ask yourself how could this be worse
if no one has died well then you know
it's only upside
so seek perspective is really the first
insight i want you to offer perspective
has anyone died here
how could this be worse what are my
blessings
what's good here what am i grateful for
perspective is a is a really important
thing to be playing with as you're
navigating
a challenging time i remember i was in a
in a in a country on a speaking tour
and it was a quite a poor country and it
was um
i was walking to the restaurant to have
a dinner
and as i walked there i had to walk
through this place where
um there was like these these shacks
and i still remember you know it was a
star-filled sky and i saw this
young girl i'm guessing she was about 12
years old
and she was sitting alone and she was
eating a piece of bread and she had the
largest
smile on her face and her eyes were
sparkling
so amidst all of that difficulty she
found perspective
and she linked to her blessings
makes me think of the lotus the lotus is
a flower that grows in swamps
and yet it's one of the most beautiful
flowers in the world so
this first way to
navigate hard times is to really
gather perspective to really ask
yourself
you know to go up to your mountaintop
and then look look across
and really get a sense of the truth of
what's going on
you know your gratitude what you're
grateful for how could this be
worse perspective also involves
remembering the shortness of
life you know we live on a tiny planet
in a large galaxy with trillions of
other planets
are our problems really that big
that's perspective when we're under an
enormous amount of stress the
first thing you have to do okay
and it's not hard to do but that means
it's also
not hard not to do the first thing you
have to do is you have to calm yourself
down when we're under an enormous amount
of stress
okay the thinking part of our brain the
imagination
part of our brain okay on solutions
isn't working as well our imagination
part of our brain is actually
focusing on all of the negative what if
i lose my job what if i have to close my
business what if i don't have enough
money
what if i can't pay for food what if i
get the virus what if
i die what if what if what if negative
and let me tell you something
let's stop bullshitting each other and
saying that no
you are not going to get it i'm not
going to get it i might get it you might
get it that's just the damn
fact now can you do something
to make sure you don't get it yeah stay
at home
okay quarantine yourself for the time
being until we can figure some more
stuff out
and minimize okay the chances of you
getting it
so that we at least could uh take care
of
you know the really sick right now then
whoever
gets it by that time our systems should
be able to take care of more
people okay but the first thing you have
to do
is you've got to get your mindset under
control you have to focus
on the uncertainty okay that you might
get it for
a minute a a quick say i might get it
what can i do about that
and then you focus on what do i do okay
to manage my finances okay so since this
particular sessions about
your finances the first thing you have
to do is you've got to get
okay your mindset calm so you can
respond instead of being in this
reactive
doom loop state okay of fear
anxiety stress uncertainty
unpredictability
when you are focusing on the on that
stuff
you're working from a disadvantaged
brain
now both of those options always exist
stress is always within you so is
calmness but you have to deliberately
deactivate the stress response center in
your brain the emotional response under
your brain is called the amygdala
and whenever there's real or imagined
threat
it fires off okay those
neurotransmitters
that cause you to feel stress and so
who's causing you to feel stress it's
not what you're watching on tv
it's the interpretation or the
repetitiveness of what you're watching
on tv or what you're reading or the
discussions you're having
so shut down some of the inputs that are
triggering your stress response hey this
john asref and do you love good books
i love to read because there's so much
wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research
pay 15 20 bucks and you learn so much
now i'm reading this awesome book called
built to serve find your purpose and
become the leader you were born to be
and one of my new friends really smart
guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and i'm going to read a little
bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star the reality is it's just
looking in the mirror and telling
yourself
the story that you want i mean and a lot
of people tell the story
that everybody else wants them to tell
right so the marketing messages so young
girls right now i'm fat i'm ugly my
hair's not long enough it's not blonde
enough it's not
brunette enough my hips are too big
they're not big enough whatever it is
right the story is being told from out
here and then you're bringing it
to you what you have to do is tell the
story you want and so for me i didn't
want to be the kid that didn't have a
dad didn't have a mom that was abused
that was
you know living in poverty that's not
the story i wanted i wanted to be the
powerful person i wanted to be the one
that
people looked up to i wanted to be the
person that that was respected with his
friends not made fun of with you know
his classmates so
i just started telling that story over
and over in the mirror i mean it was as
simple as that and then i started
you started telling a new story about
i'm that kind of me yeah instead of i
am a for example uh troubled youth
right i was told that oh you're just
you're a troubled youth west so we need
to help you and i'm like no i'm not a
troubled youth like i'm
i am a youth right so let's get rid of
the word trouble i'm a happy youth i'm
a playful youth i'm a successful youth
like put the word fill the word in there
that you want and if you believe the
word trouble then much like the stutter
thing then that's what you are right
you're just perpetuating that
stereotype or that conversation more and
more and whenever i did that whenever i
wish i'd have my moments of weakness
where i would try and try and then fail
and as soon as i'd start like just kind
of okay you know by just like everything
like
frumpy and just like all right i'm just
gonna give up that's when my life
became worse and worse and i started
making worse decisions and then i
started realizing like wait
if i just keep pushing over here it's
hard it's hard as hell there's no
easy answer to this there's no like okay
well every morning at six o'clock you
know wake up and
meditate for 10 minutes and tell
yourself you're beautiful and then go
like it's not
it doesn't work like that it's a
constant battle and you're gonna have
moments of complete and total defeat
where it's just like
what am i doing like why do i keep
trying to do this and if for me
again it was just reminding myself of i
want these happy moments i want to have
this life
and and so it just it started to
perpetuate in little things that i would
see like
a new friend at school or a relationship
or you know would start to like
blossom into different things and then
with the business it would be
oh wow like i can go and sell and i can
do and as soon as i started like seeing
just a little bit of progress
then that motivated me for the next and
the next and just build and build and
build and i'd still say i'm building
like i still have issues
but it's just focusing on that that
different conversation telling a
different story and the story you want
and that's the first thing i tell youth
is like
look don't look at my story don't look
at someone else's story
what's the story you want we are under
no spiritual or moral
obligation to experience fear
lack of any kind lack of joy sadness
depression anxiety and stress
now your mind's first reaction might be
now wouldn't that be nice if that were
really true
but in this moment you must remind
yourself no
this is true
i know that i have dominion over what i
think and those emotions
are always the result of what i am
thinking
toxic thoughts and emotions are entirely
needless and they need not be present
in my mind or life now the solution to a
negative thought or emotion
is not to ignore them but to meet them
with the active engagement
of the truth this means engage them with
the truth
of your being your true nature your i am
nature which is the creative force of
the universe
so try this i am whole
i am complete i am safe
i am prepared and equipped to meet any
challenge with peace
and calm now honestly think about
what you have focused your thoughts on
that the creator would not have
thought for you with you or about you
and then what have you not
thought about that god would have you
think
search yourself for what you focused
upon
and then change your mind to think
with your true nature which is anchored
in the mind
of the creator fear lack
lack of joy lack of anything sadness
depression
and anxiety and stress this
need not be we're coming back
into atlanta i'll never forget this
moment
the plane's maybe 50 feet from landing
we're just coming in
things seem to be going fine and all of
a sudden we hit a windshear
and the plane immediately dropped and
when it hit the runway
it didn't hit it square and i i thought
to myself
we're going to crash immediately when
those wheels
touched the the runway the pilot just
pulled that plane back up in the air
instantly in fact
so quickly that i it just it took me
back and
we got in the air we circled a couple of
times came back down had a safe landing
i got off the plane
kissed the ground and then the pilot got
out and i kissed him i said oh my gosh
thank you very much and then i asked him
i said
i got to talk to you i said you just
took that plane up in the air so
fast i just wow how did you
think of doing that so quickly i mean it
was just like immediately you had the
plane back up in the air
i said when did you think about that and
he looked at me and smiled he said i
thought about that
20 years ago and then he told me
as a pilot i've thought about every
possible way
and condition that would cause the plane
to wreck
and i've asked myself in every scenario
if this happens
what am i going to do and he said i made
a decision
20 years ago that if i hit the runway
wrong i would immediately get the plane
back in the air
because there's just a lot more give and
take in the air than there is on the
ground and that's very true
when he told me that i thought that's
crisis management managing the crisis
before there's a crisis in other words
anticipating
what is the problem what is going to be
the issue
and then getting answers for it
perhaps the best answer for crisis
management is
not what you think when the crisis
appears
but what you've thought before the
crisis happens
i was having one time lunch with rudy
giuliani and we were talking about 9 11
and when the planes went into the towers
and i asked him when he was at breakfast
he was at breakfast when they came and
told him
i said what did you think he said
immediately i thought it was a terrorist
attack because
those those towers are in no way in the
path of the airlines
and then he said john before i got to my
car i was already talking to the
chief of police the ch and and and
and the fire people and and he said we
already had a plan because
he said we've been practicing for a year
what to do in one of those skyscrapers
if
if there would ever be an attack he said
we knew what to do
i guess what i'm saying is that we're
all going to have
crisis and we're going to have to manage
them we can't anticipate
everything but we can't anticipate some
things i would just
encourage you think ahead plan ahead
ask yourself the hard questions perhaps
when the crisis
comes it won't be quite the crisis it
would have been
because you thought about it on the
front end everything
happens for a reason someone just
recently asked what does that mean
lisa when it says everything happens for
a reason well
i have four things one it's a mindset
it's a mindset that allows us to divorce
ourselves from our need to control all
things
lord i know i need to continuously
divorce myself from the mindset that i
can control
all things so number one i think making
the statement everything happens for a
reason allows you to relax
and let go of it and really divorce
yourself from the belief system
that you need to control all things and
number two
i think that it lends to the this great
statement that i once heard
years ago i don't know who i heard it
from first i didn't create it
it just has been a lifesaver for me and
that's the quote
man's rejection is god's protection
for me that means when things don't go
the way
i thought they should go sometimes it's
not
it's not only okay it's for the best
that there's something i couldn't even
see now the word man is used loosely
man's rejection is god's protection can
also be a woman
could also be a job it could also be a
project could also be a career
it could be anything but for me it says
when this door doesn't open for you it's
because
you're being protected not only is there
another door
but that door wouldn't serve you at the
highest level if you went any further
man's rejection is god's protection it's
been life for me
and three to recognize there are
blessings
even in the no even in the
breakup even in the release of a job
even in the you didn't get the proposal
even in the that thing that you thought
you should have
in the know lives blessings as well
and four really understanding
that everything happens for a reason
is an invitation to see beyond
the inconvenience in the moment
into the learning lesson everything
happens
for a reason watch this everything
happens right here
for a reason it's an invitation
for you to see beyond the inconvenience
beyond the rejection beyond the loss
of a job a career a loved one
for the lesson or the opportunity
sometimes the hardest thing for you to
do
is to reach past pain and grab an
opportunity to learn reach past pain
and grab some compassion reach past
pain and grab the blessings of the
existence
especially in loss but i believe that
there's an
invitation you don't have to accept the
invitation
but there's in every difficult moment
there's an invitation to see beyond the
inconvenience
to see beyond the pain to what's the
learning lesson what's the opportunity
what's the blessing
reach out to one person one person
because if you have a plus one
on things that in itself will change
your whole map
in the resource map and that person you
basically say
i'm thinking about doing a book club i'm
thinking of doing a men's group
i'm thinking of doing a yoga class i'm
thinking of doing a rave party i'm
thinking of
checking out the sex party whichever one
it is
most of the time people will thank you
because they've had the same thoughts
and they haven't called anybody either
so that's the first thing is that if you
reach out
you're doing not just yourself a favor
but you're actually doing a favor to
somebody else's way
resource maps are the maps where we
write down who we know
who we could help who's in our
neighborhood who's in our building it's
not just what is available for you
but it's also what you can do for others
which is probably the most important
thing that will make us not feel lonely
you know the second thing is groups
there's a lot of pre-existing groups
you know i hear a lot of men who don't
know to reach out and feel like
you know that's not what they typically
have done is to call somebody to talk
you know every man has incredible groups
all free
you know for men to come together but
there's all kinds of groups alumni
groups as well
you know then there is the stuff you do
for yourself
and i think because we're sitting all
the time because we're in front of these
you know
zoomers that we have become it's really
important that we do things that
involve movement you know and breath so
it's from
simple grounding ourselves and doing
breathing slow
breathing you know that regulates us to
taking showers to walking outside
to having our cores while we are in
movement as well but
the main thing i think is that we can
find
freedom in confinement through our
imagination
and your imagination for those of you
who are apart from your partners
is what at this moment is going to fill
the empty space
of the geography through your
imagination you can cross borders
through your imaginations you can
imagine you're sitting next to each
other and if you think that is weird
just look at
children play they do this all the time
we do used to do this too we just forgot
so engage your imagination reach out to
other people
think about the things that are
self-suiting that show you that you're
worthy of taking care of yourself
then you become good company to yourself
as well and every one of those
will create a little nibble
into your loneliness now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
through jump to 91
and when you commit publicly like
putting your comment down below with
your plan
it jumps in 95 that's what i want for
you i want you to take action
your dreams are too important your life
matters your mission
has to happen so question of the day
your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to celebrate alongside with
you
being an entrepreneur is one of the
hardest things you'll ever do in your
life
whether you go all in financially or not
you're going to go all in emotionally
and a lot of people they can't cut it
they can't get the calluses fast enough
and so they quit that's going to be one
of the biggest tests for you
as you get off and build your business
do you have the mental fortitude to keep
going keep driving keep building your
business
in the face of all obstacles it's the
ultimate endurance test
it's the ultimate test to see what
you're made of when i first started my
company
i knew it was going to be hard but i
didn't think it would be this hard
you never think it's going to be as hard
as it actually is i was making 300
a month i turned down 100 000 a year
six figures working for my dream job
company to make 300
a month and own 30 of a company i eat
beans for lunch every day
the same bean salad for lunch mix beans
with olive oil and herbs and garlic and
salt
a little pepper because it was cheap and
it would fill me up
and when i wanted to splurge i would go
to the store and get the
the chunky campbell soup clam chowder
it's a little bit more expensive would
also fill me up
when we went to celebrate a win we would
go to mcdonald's and get a mcdonald's
french fries large fries
and share between the three of us
because that's what we could afford
couldn't afford the whole meal and even
to this day the smell of mcdonald's
french fries
means victory for me it's the most
unhealthy thing in the world but it
still means victory
for me i made it even harder on myself
and that i isolated myself and i didn't
tell my friends that i was struggling
i had to pick one thing a month that i
could go to one friendly
you know social pizza and beer kind of
thing per month
because at 20 bucks i didn't have
because i'm only making 300 a month
so i isolated myself i turned inwards
i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends
who are off making 80 100 000 a year
starting salary at a university and not
making 300 bucks a month
i was too embarrassed and ashamed and so
i told them
i'm hustling i'm living the
entrepreneurial life you know i'm
grinding
but really i was struggling i had no
idea what i was doing
this thing was tearing me apart
and it got to the point where i actually
quit on my business partner i told him i
quit
it's easy to quit on something and not
get results when you know that you're
not putting in the effort
but i was putting in the effort every
single day showing up to my business
partner's
dining room table because everything
else is too small in his place to to fit
us
putting in the effort every single day
trying to build and grow this business
and just it wasn't working i felt
worthless as a human
like why are we not getting results when
we start to get results
and i was fed up and tired and i told my
quit like i need to find a way to
to to be useful
to feel valuable as a human and so i
told my quit
and then i woke up the next day and said
i can't quit because i haven't given it
everything that i've got
and so there's a two-step process that
saved me
that i hope will save you if you're
feeling down and out
and it's tough and you're not getting
results
the first step is use regret to fuel you
i imagine my life at 100 looking back on
this moment
saying would i regret quitting
it's very rarely the things that you do
that you regret it's the things that you
don't do
so would i regret not continuing
but i regret not giving in my all and i
try to adopt the mantra that
i would rather know and fail than not
know i would rather know and fail than
not know
so i had to see this through even if the
answer was total failure
even if it never worked out i had to see
it all the way through just to know
because otherwise that regret would eat
me up
[Music]
and so number one use regret when you're
struggling when it's not working out
when you're not getting results
imagine yourself being 100 years old
looking back and saying if you quit now
if you stop if you don't keep going will
you regret it number two
is model success the next thing that
saved me was
i asked myself that next morning after i
quit and then decided i need to go back
because i can't live with regret
i asked myself who has done this before
who has built the software company up
i can't be the only person who's tried
to do this
and i looked at bill gates who started
microsoft and not how he makes an extra
million dollars now but zero to one how
did he do that how did that happen
i studied his success i modeled to
success i applied it to my company
and pretty shortly got my first deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars
that may not seem like a lot of money
but to me back then it was
it was hitting the lottery i'm making
300 bucks a month now i just made a deal
for 13 and a half thousand that was hope
that was real that was putting the money
in my bank account
you know that was being able to have a
full meal at mcdonald's
and more important it gave me a model
that i could do again and again and
again i close another deal and another
deal and another deal
and our business started to take off
energy to me is just like a feeling or a
sense but
in the research we had to codify three
separate kinds of energy
one is mental energy which is straight
up your mental focus and stamina
right to do activities right
right without just like tuning off right
because that's hard
yeah i mean i'm sure some people have
started writing a paper and you have to
page one and a half and your lan your
brain went somewhere else totally
um you were just tired the other one is
emotional energy
which is the quality of positive versus
negative emotion and the last one
was a spiritual energy a sensation that
they were in flow or not
um and what we found out is high
performers have
incredibly intentional habits to protect
that energy um you know when we were on
tour with her oprah
she uh when oprah was on tour she tells
this great story
about how she was so moved by someone
who's on her show
who went into a green room and was
telling over the story of she saw this
sign that said
please be responsible for the energy you
bring into this space
and i'm always saying please be
responsible for the energy you project
into the world
yes high performers are so critically
aware
of what their energy is their feeling
and how they're treating other people
it's profound and the way that they do
that is they have a lot of habits that
protect their well-being so
they're truly seeking to optimize health
they care about nutrition on the world's
largest study on productivity that's
ever been done
found out that on average the world's
most productive
one percent of people take a break every
52 minutes
every 52 minutes they take a break now
if you ask them did you need the break
they're like
no they could power through all day
they have the mental energy and stamina
they could go but they take the break
like a pit stop
like in like a nascar right the car the
cars actually don't need to stop right
then
they stop to change things out and
optimize things so they can keep going
faster
yes we have to do that in our own lives
so some of them that's meditation
um one that's incredibly important for
everybody here
especially the united states right now
in the united states of america 72 of
americans are overweight or obese
and that has incredible health
repercussions that is you're sicker
longer you
die earlier you report less happiness
throughout the majority of your life you
pass some of that behavior onto children
like it's a very big deal and it's not a
judgment of a
of a body shaming thing it is a your
quality of life in every measurable way
that they have in science
shows it's not as good and we want you
to feel okay
what high performers they work
out five times per week
40 more likely than an underperformer
now that workout might be literally like
you take a 45-minute walk
at after dinner sure it doesn't mean
you're climbing around the mountain it
doesn't mean you have to have a sick
pack or anything you move every day
and so they're protecting that you know
i think that's what's really important
there they have active lifestyles
not because it's easy because they know
the alternative of
burnout and fatigue will hurt their
performance
if we've been able to stay alive
at all alive and
future thinking alive and having enough
courage to care for each other
enough courage to love
and know that we're probably one percent
free
i mean let's what one percent of 60
million
free of uh of complaints
imagine who would we
be who would we
be if we were 1 of 600 million
6 billion what would happen
i tell you one thing i think war would
be laughed out of the room
i think the very word somebody said
warren
another person would say you mean am i
supposed to kill somebody because he
doesn't
agree with me i don't think so
just imagine people would speak kinder
more kindly to each other courtesy would
be
invited back into the living room into
the bedroom into the children's room
into the kitchen if one percent
of our world
was complaint free
we would care more about the children
and realize that every child is our
child
the black one and the white one the
pretty one the plain one
the asian and the muslim the japanese
and the jewish everyone
is our child if we were just one percent
free of complaint imagine
that we would stop blaming other people
for our mistakes
[Music]
and hating them because they caused the
mistake
in our minds just imagine if we laughed
more frequently
if we had the unmitigated
courage to touch each other
it would be just the beginning of
paradise
you know thank you i
um have a tendency to
judge myself based on other people's
opinions of me and that's sort of where
a lot of my anxieties have always been
and
something that i'm trying to change but
i don't know you know
one year of doing that isn't going to
solve that and so i think you know now
with the show ending
and moving forward into my life
and um deciding what i want to do
i just worry that if people are very
vocal about what they think on my life
that it might affect
me um even if it just upsets me
like that kind of scares me because when
i get upset it makes me um
just forget a lot of the things that
i've worked so hard to try and
understand
because i put that energy on that upset
or people's opinions
exactly as opposed to the good things
you've done yeah or your mission or what
you want to create
yeah and that's when it starts creeping
back in you know it's like one knock on
one
thing you read and then it can just
spiral and i know that i'm still very
capable of doing that
so it's just that's what my biggest fear
is for the future because i don't want
it to stop me from doing things i want
to do
yeah um but other people's opinions do
opinions do still
like really affect me you've got two
choices
every day of your life you're either
optimistic or you're pessimistic you're
either seeing what's good
or you're seeing what's bad my whole
life even when i was like in
a very different place i would always
just say seven billion people
now it's seven seven seven point seven
billion people
where do i rank for all that i got for
all the negativity where do i rank
am i better than the person that's
terminally ill that has a lot of money
that's gonna die in a month yep
am i better than somebody who's living
in a cage in parts of the world that we
don't even want to look at
yeah and so to me this is a mindset game
there's a tremendous faith that has to
come
in believing that the real
is the right way even if it doesn't look
like it in this moment
and and to stop arguing with reality
and to figure out how are we gonna now
live in accordance with reality
you know um this is the reality
so now how do we what are we going to do
um rather than
let's pretend this isn't the reality
yeah let me take whatever drugs i have
to take to pretend that this isn't the
reality
you go do whatever you have to do to
hide to pretend that this isn't the
reality
and then let's just see where that leads
when you're saying
i know who i am and i'm telling you it's
the thread
that runs through everything it's the
thing that allows you to
stand in your own truth and one of the
things for
years that maya angelou used to say to
me is baby you need to know
that you alone are enough
you alone are enough
by the time i started feeding tom i i
actually
i didn't know what was wrong with me at
that point because the symptoms seemed
so physical and seemed so brain-based
i was scared if i was honest i wouldn't
have imagined that
as i dove down and began to peel back
the onion and unpack all of this that
this was related
to overwhelming emotions in childhood
that was not my first path of
exploration
my first path of exploration was what is
wrong with me
um by that time just kind of going back
on the physical side of things for me
i had had headaches my whole life i had
had brain fog or kind of that
that fogginess not really feeling like
my brain was awake
all of the time my whole life out of
nowhere as i entered into my 30s i
started to forget my words
mid-sentence memory issues that i always
kind of had
now seemed i seem to have a really hard
time even remembering things that
happened last week
for instance and then out of the blue i
started fainting so of course i was like
this must be something wrong with my
brain
what is it and when i dove into research
i then met all of this you know work on
epigenetics and
the effect that our daily choices and or
events that happened to us have on our
physical bodies
diving in deeper i really understood my
nervous system
and now i understood my fainting as the
effects of accumulated years of living
in that dysregulated nervous system
so now that i understood what the cause
of it was
which goes into my definition of
holistic holistic for me
not only means honoring our mind our
body and our soul the interconnectedness
of our being
it also means exploring what for many of
us
are the deeper underlying imbalances
that are causing
what we're calling symptoms or even
diagnosis or syndromes
right so now that i understood oh
for me this fainting could be a
symptom of something deeper could be a
symptom of how i'm treating my body
and how dysregulated my nervous system
is
so as i began to dive into this research
i noticed something else
how disconnected i was to my body so
once i build the foundation of
consciousness that we just talked about
once i began to teach myself how to
safely
inhabit my body i began to do some
nervous system
regulation techniques and tools the
quickest and easiest one that we all
carry around with us
is around breath work and i started to
tune into
how was i breathing just checking in
with my natural
flow of breath and i realized that like
many people who struggle with anxiety i
had a really
shallow chest breath i noticed that
sometimes
tom when i'm really stressed out i hold
my breath i actually don't
really breathe much at all and what i
learned is
each time i do both of those things
either just breathe really shallowly
or i'm holding my breath i'm actually
contributing to my anxiety because i'm
keeping my nervous system locked in that
fight-or-flight mode
so i learned a new way to breathe i
learned how to use my belly
which was hard at first because all of
my posture
was reflective of all of this
constriction and all of this
threatening kind of posture and stance
of a lifetime
though once i accessed my belly i
learned that i could learn how to bring
teach my body can you walk people
through how you did that because
um belly breathing diaphragmatic
breathing changed
my life so i'd be curious to know what
tools you use for that
yeah so for a lot of us um who struggle
with our posture
it's hard um so back straight shoulders
back
so i started laying down it was
difficult for me so i would
begin my practice either right before
bed or right when i woke up when i was
already laying
and for me it started with just a small
daily promise
of five breaths from my deep belly area
for me putting my hand on my belly
physically so i could feel it
when it would expand and when it would
deflate was really helpful so that was
just a daily promise
every time every morning or right before
bed i would put my hand on my belly
and just practice practice practice but
then like i said i wanted to become more
aware of how i was using my breath
all day long and then building on that
foundation
can i harness my breath all day long
when now life's happening and i have the
actual things to be stressed out about
right
can i use my breath to regulate myself
in those moments so it because
out of all you've learned over a billion
dollars failure mistakes all the success
books
he said what have you what could you
tell me it was just one thing which is a
hard thing and i didn't think about it
in advance of course yeah
and i said he said what would it be i
said
learn to observe your thoughts quicker
it took me till i was in my probably 40s
to really understand that your thoughts
lie to you
and your thoughts will steer you down
the road like
when your thoughts have you ever you're
listening have you ever um like
thought a girlfriend did something wrong
and all of a sudden you're all fired up
like how could she do this
you're emotionally responding you get
there and you find it was all it didn't
even happen right or like i can't
believe my buddies went to the
movie and they didn't invite me and you
realize they left you a voice memo
like things can happen to fires up that
are just our perception of the situation
or insecurities that are bubbling up or
whatever it is i mean think about when i
when i say that is like think of
thoughts right two identical
situations there's a car accident two
people are involved
one circumstance someone gets out and
screams oh how can you do this i'm going
to be late my insurance is going to go
up what are you stupid how can you do
this
you like that you see it yeah then you
see like are you blind right that's one
same circumstance right someone else
does it and gets out and says
they say i'm sorry oh no big deal it's
cars it's metal we have insurance
nobody's hurt who cares hey can i buy
you a coffee you look a little shaken up
yeah right so when someone says no when
somebody says get real
or this is what actually happened
nothing is what actually happened
what happened is this the sich is the
perception
of a situation now i know you probably
heard that a million times but maybe
this is the first time you actually
think about it
your situation right now is being held
back or
being fueled simply by by what you think
you have
right and when you change that story you
change your life like
and one of the ways that i think is
really important is if you feel like you
can't start your own company because you
don't have money and you're not smart
enough
then go google john paul de jourio and
look at his story that's who started
videography
on the show what's that we actually
interviewed i love john paul yeah right
go google richard branson
tony robbins me everybody i know
everybody i was with this weekend
none of them started with money none of
them were like hey here's a hundred
grand go start your business
right blueprint on how to do it yeah
three quarters of people were this
weekend didn't go to college like
not that you find someone who you say i
can't do i don't have a supportive
spouse
find someone who didn't have a
supportive house and they did it anyway
and
prove that the story that your
subconscious has developed to protect
yourself
like literally when it pops up that that
limiting belief that doubt talk that
that inner villain says it's the wrong
time wrong president wrong economy
just prove it wrong and call it a liar
and start figuring a way to empower that
we hear patience is a virtue
i suppose it probably is but i think
patience real patience is an expression
of deep understanding you see
everything happens when it's supposed to
happen everything in this universe
happens by law
we set targets and we need things to
happen we need something to come or
someone to do something
and frequently we get frustrated because
it isn't happening when we think it
should happen
our problem is we're not thinking we
believe
we're in charge we are not in charge we
are in charge of building the idea and
holding the idea
everything else happens automatic it
happens by law
all ideas have a gestation or an
incubation period
i'm told when we plant a carrot in the
area of the world that i live it takes
approximately 70 days for that carrot to
grow
and manifest in form when
the seed for the baby's planted it takes
approximately 280 days
and we're usually patient we will wait
the 280 days why
because we know it's going to take
approximately 280 days
well just because we don't know how long
it's going to take
doesn't mean that it isn't operating by
the same laws everything operates by law
so if we gain an understanding that all
the ideas in our mind will ultimately
move into form
that's what andrew carnegie taught
napoleon hill
carnegie was hill's mentor he said any
idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered
but begin it wants to clothe itself in
the most convenient and appropriate form
available you might want to listen to
that two or three times
burn it into your mind gain an
understanding of it
and you will know that whatever you're
working on takes a period of time
no one knows what the gestation period
is for an idea we only know we can
shorten it through
concentration through focus
and when you understand that you'll
become more patient and when you're more
patient
you're living in a much more beautiful
vibration you'll be a more pleasant
person to be around
you will enjoy yourself more patience
it's the result of understanding so
watch you have momentum look at me
you have momentum i'm gonna be yamabi
i'm gonna be your momentum
and then bam you you get bam and then
bam the waves of life hit
bam and then many people have a set back
a setback could be a relationship
it was looking so good the first three
dates
now you got to change your numbers
right
a set back
divorce setback financial setback
physical setback illness setback
somebody passed in our lives set back
when most people have a setback watch
they take a step back then a setback
and a step back in a setback
in a step back and now watch you find
yourself so
far away from the real you
and people many times sit
in that setback i don't mind you
going through a tough time and staying
there for a week or a month
or a year but a decade
so some people sit say sit some people
settled say settle and that's where
we're headed today because
a lot of you that are watching here
today you have been
settling in your setback and you have
therefore become a
discount version of yourself
well you don't understand what i've been
through tim's story
mr life coach to the stars
oh really we all been through hell but
to quote winston churchill when you're
going through hell
don't stop don't pitch a tent in hell
don't build a holiday inn inhale come on
somebody don't even put a ritz carlton
in your hair
why don't you like the size you are
is it okay because i don't believe in
losing weight
to be skinny i believe in getting
healthy
because of how it makes you feel yeah so
if you love the size that you are
and it's healthy you should stay the
size that you are
but if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say i'm a piece of
or i'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror
all of those things tell me what is it
let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this
to yourself when you're alone
don't you i want you to say it out loud
because it's
it's not okay to say this stuff to
yourself
what do you say to yourself that we're
not going to say anymore i'm disgusting
i'm disgusting what else
i like the way i look i hate the way
that i look i hate the way i feel i hate
the way that i feel
okay what do you want what do you
deserve
to feel good when they walk down the
street yes yes you do
see i think at the heart of this i think
at the heart of this is a belief
that you don't deserve to feel that way
so who taught you to feel that that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it holly
maybe when i was like that's usually
when it happens
so what i want you to do is i want you
to leave here and what you're going to
go to war against is not your weight
you're going to go to war against the
pattern in your head okay
because the longer you invalidate
yourself the less motivated you're going
to be to change
yeah because you're beating yourself
down so we got to start with
not fixing you you're not broken
you're perfect how you are holly you are
i know you don't feel that way but i
feel that way yeah it's the pattern up
here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a zero tolerance policy
for this like i'm not worth it i don't
deserve it i'm a piece of
this um three all that it's like an
axe you got that and then you're going
to come up what can we say
instead i can do this i do that
i can do this but more important i think
it needs to be more heart-centered
i deserve to feel good
yeah i deserve to have what i want
watch me go get it let me give you a
couple more things you said that
this is kind of hard our society makes
plenty of room for complacency or
laziness we're
rarely surrounded by accountability
we're also rarely surrounded by sugar
free vanilla lattes
but when i really want one i somehow
find a way to get one what did you mean
when you said that
uh you know the idea that
if you want something it's like if if
you really want something you'll find a
way if you don't you'll find an excuse
yes yeah yes so gonna get resourceful
yes
and i think there is this um
i feel like the tide is shifting and i
hope that this is true but
so often i feel like women especially
like it feels like their life is living
them
it like it feels like life is it's all
just happening to them they're sort of
getting pulled along with the tide
they're not making any choices they're
not taking control
um so and it and it's the norm right
it's it's normal to go
you're exhausted because you were
dealing with the kids all day and then
you're going to go watch
you know netflix all night and drink too
much and numb yourself to what's going
on and then wake up tomorrow and do the
same thing again
and it because they don't ever have that
space because they never take a step
back and look at their life from like 50
000 foot view they don't even understand
that they have control of how to change
it oh boy
and you might not have the tools i'm
going to quote your podcast to you again
or i think it was yours but um joe
dispenza
said in an age of this much free
information
ignorance is a choice correct so you
might not know
how to change things you might not know
how to get healthy you might not know
how to change your marriage
all of but it all exists on the internet
right now for free
tell me about this thing that was
hardest to start in all the things
you've started whether it was
relationships whether it was
quest whether it was impact through
women of impact now like what was the
toughest thing for you personally to
start and why
um i don't know about the starting but
the hardest thing i had to do was be a
housewife
so you know and i don't say that like i
think if you choose to be a housewife it
can be the most beautiful thing in your
life
but i didn't choose to be and so when we
started
on our entrepreneurial journey it was
all like we want to make movies let's
just make enough money to make our own
films
you know earning money shouldn't be too
difficult um
and so we went into that thinking okay
i'm just gonna be
a housewife for a year and our plan was
tom was going to go
um basically go after the money and we
looked at all the successful people in
the world and we looked at steve jobs
and we're like how does he live his life
and we saw that he doesn't take time to
choose his colour shirt because we only
have a certain amount of decisions we
can make in one year in a day
so tom was like okay well if i took off
the decisions off my plate from the
house
then i can really concentrate on the
money so we made an agreement
that for a year i would be the
stay-at-home wife and i would do
everything from him from the moment he
woke up his clothes would be laid out
for him
from um going and going to the gym and
coming back his work clothes were laid
out for him his lunch was made like
every single thing outside the business
i handled
um and so i thought okay this is what as
a partnership we're going in this
together we've agreed what we're doing
how we're going to do it we've given
ourselves 12 months
12 months came two years came
three years came four years came before
we knew it was an eight year journey
and that was the hardest thing because i
hadn't planned on it it wasn't what i
wanted to be it wasn't what i wanted to
do
but i had almost tricked myself enough
that every day i was doing something
that was meaningful
that i wasn't addressing how i actually
felt right like i kept telling myself
you're doing this for this purpose
you're doing it
for your husband you're doing it for
your mission you're doing it because you
guys agreed that you're gonna do it and
at no point
did i stop and go but i don't enjoy it
anymore and
that was the hardest thing because i
would fill my days with mundane things
but just enough to get pleasure out of
them so
i would clean and i would find pleasure
in cleaning because i so i could get
through the day
and that became an eight-year journey
where looking back now i was
at my most miserable because i didn't
address how i
felt and now in business and everything
i do
i reassess but i didn't have a growth
mindset back then
so now i'm just like am i enjoying what
i'm doing what is my life's purpose and
am i doing that every single day and i
didn't do that back then
when you can be trusted with the small
things and the small moments you get
trusted with more and more and more and
so like
it helps to just in that moment and it's
in those painful moments that you
realize how powerful you are we all know
that like you
really recognize it and and what you
said was beautiful about not
rushing through the pain because and and
you know this example's probably been
shared before but if you have a wound
and you've cut yourself
it's like you can't rush
the healing you can't rush it if you
broke your arm
i mean and you've been through so many
bodily injuries you can't
rush the process it's gonna take six
weeks minimum to heal broken
oh yeah and you've got to sit through
that there's no
injections you can take there's no
videos you can watch there's nothing you
can listen to
but our challenge is we try and rush
through the pain
rather than reflect through the pain we
try to rush the healing process try to
rush the healing and you can't rush
healing and
healing is meant to be slow because it
buys you time it buys you reflection it
gives you so much space
to slow down to slow down and that's
what your body is calling out from this
is our emergency like how many times
have you earned it when you slow down
you slow down and that's when you fall
ill
because guess what your body has been
trying to tell you to slow down
when you feel pain so i write about it
and think like pain
makes you pay attention yeah that's what
pain's for
pain notice this notice this notice me
look at me it's crazy it's like a
crying baby craving for attention when a
baby's crying
you don't just go eyes crying you just
go oh yeah we'll just put it in another
room and forget about it right like you
go to and you find its needs whereas
without pain when something's painful
we're just like
oh yeah i'll just forget about it i'll
escape from it i'll do something else
you have to go
into that i mean i'm not the person the
pain that's said
or whatever yeah 100 that's that's
usually our response is what can i do to
numb this work more
have sex more drink more whatever is
more whatever it is rather than let me
actually become alert and guess what the
pain just gets higher and higher and
higher and higher because unfortunately
until it really hurts
we don't stop or you need more and more
to numb it with
so true i hit 30 i go through a really
bad i moved to la for a girl she breaks
up with me the day i move here
after she after she demanded i moved
here oh wow i made an ultimatum which
was already a wreck of red flag and i
already had knew my intuition was off
but i was like
you know i did stupid things my whole
life so it's all good uh but it was the
greatest lesson for me like moving here
for a girl
when i said i would never move for a
girl was the greatest lesson
that um i wouldn't be doing the podcast
without moving to la
feeling stuck feeling trapped i was in
la traffic
going through this breakup i went
through a business partnership breakup
and i was just like everything was
breaking down it felt like
i was stuck in traffic after a few
months in l.a and i was like why am i
here like i hate la
i love new york city where i was living
pursuing my dream of this handball stuff
making tons of money i felt like on top
of the world and i moved to l.a for a
girl i feel stuck
everything's falling apart and i'm
trying to go like two miles it takes me
an hour
right i went the wrong time my hair why
am i here
and i started thinking to myself there's
got to be other people that are feeling
this
as well who are stuck in traffic
everyone just looked miserable around me
for this traffic in l.a
i was like i bet people around the world
are like stuck in traffic
because i was walking everywhere in new
york i didn't experience this
i was like i bet there's people who are
just stuck in life like i feel right now
and a couple of my friends had podcasts
and i was like i wonder about this
podcasting i wonder if i could
find a channel to create something to
help people who are stuck
so i called my two friends who had
podcasts right then this is in 2012.
before podcasts were a thing yeah and i
was like tell me about this podcast
thing do you like it what's what's the
deal they were like
i love it both of them so like i love it
it's the most fun thing i'm doing
like it's helping my business my brand
and i just i'm in love with it and i go
if these guys can do this i can figure
this out and
right then it was like the path i was
like what would it be called like
i don't know i've just always been
focused on like trying to achieve
amazing things great
things but i've sucked in school my
whole life
like i wish they taught these certain
lessons from sports and mentors that i'm
finding like in school
definitely it's like the school of like
schools go to the hill and change the
curriculum because
exactly right i think it's terrible well
a lot of it's pointless that's
really the point of it they don't teach
they teach us how to study for
uh a test but they don't teach us how to
deal with our emotions when we fail it
100
they teach us how to memorize things but
don't teach us how to communicate
properly and you know lies things so
just how to avoid failure not be
successful
exactly so i came up with a podcast then
and during that time right after that
time i also like
got in a fight i was in a fight on the
basketball court because everything i
was
so used to when things weren't going my
way reacting
negatively with anger because i didn't
know how to communicate my emotions
i didn't know how to be yeah we hadn't
practiced it express how i feel
because in school it was acceptable to
when someone
upsetted you to fight them or to slam a
locker and be
angry it was acceptable because that was
kind of the behavior
that you expected from someone like that
like a young boy
because every time i tried to express my
emotions i was made fun of
and laughed at and called weak so i
never knew i was able to
and so at this time business breakdown
where they should break down getting in
fights
and just feeling stuck it was a moment
where i said
okay my friend was here at the fight who
works with me now and he was like i
don't want to hang out with you anymore
whoa this is one of my best friends
college football worked together
everything was like i want to hang out
with you aggressive
i was like wow my best friend doesn't
want to hang out with me that's
that's like time to look within you know
what i mean
yeah no one not everyone else is wrong
anymore yep it's time to look at myself
and i started saying i'm gonna shed all
this stuff i think it's hard for us to
make a change in our life unless there's
some type of breakdown
and the bigger the breakdown the more
we're able to
look and say okay what's working and
what's not working right it's really
hard to change anything we have going on
bigger breakthrough that's it i mean and
it was kind of a perfect storm and i
started going to a lot of
workshops and got asked for coaching
from a lot of people
talking to their anyone i could talk to
who i thought could help me i would
talk to i would do their program and
that's what helped me finally start to
break down the walls it was like
opening up about all my traumas of my
past and just addressing it
acknowledging it talking friends or to
like a therapist uh i
started in like kind of group workshops
where i opened up for the first time in
25 years about being sexually abused
wow that has to be like pretty emotional
yeah
i was like i'm taking this to the grave
i was like no one needs to know this
because no one will love me if they knew
this about me
right no one accept me everyone don't
think i'm a what whatever i just made up
stories
blame you everything yeah and so when i
started talking about that i was like
and people actually accepted me for
talking about i was like wow
like let me just share everything you
know then i just like like well if
that's gonna blow you away like yeah
but i was so scared to talk about my
emotions and i said man i don't want to
be scared of this anymore so let me do
it
talk about it all the time until i'm not
scared
and then i had power over all of it well
i was going to just say you take its
power away
i took my power back from it and listen
i still get triggered every now and then
and things happen and i'm like reactive
but i'm so quick to be like okay you're
going back to a place
of scarcity or fear of insecurity yeah
and that's not who you are that's not
who you want to be
so i reflect on it i address it i create
a new commitment to myself
i meditate i work out make my bed
and i focus on just trying to be a
better person every day life is a fight
for territory
and once you stop fighting for what you
want what you don't want will
automatically take over give you an
example
27 years ago i was diagnosed
with prostate cancer about 27 years ago
my gosh
when is it fourth stage cancer and four
stage prostate cancer
my psa was 2 400.
and and so dr alfred golson said mr
brown
you have fourth stage cancer i said do
he said yes
and it's metastasized to seven areas of
your body
and it's eaten 43 of your t1 vertebrae
i said whoa he said what why are you
smiling did you hear what i just said i
said yeah
he said why are you smiling i said man
seven it's my lucky number
i was going forward the 17th joshua
marshall on the walls of jericho
seven times naaman dipped himself in the
river jordan seven times seven is my
lucky number
we looked at his nurse said this is a
strange one
so i said can you give me a second
opinion he said yes
and you're ugly too
[Applause]
he said but you got this you got this
i don't tell patients that they're
terminally ill what i say is my
knowledge and my ability
and my skills are terminated now you and
god
figure this out he determines the
prognosis
you got this and as a result how people
live their lives as you know
as a result of the story they believe
about themselves he
interrupted my story and i left there
with a heart
full of faith not a heart full of fear
ziggs said most people in a
fearful situation they forget everything
and run but they're a small number the
road to life is straight and narrow a
few there be that find it
who face everything and rise
[Music]
if you want to learn how to overcome
failures and achieve success
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there put yourself in
uncomfortable situations
staying positive i think people don't
realize it takes work
people quit when they don't know why
they're doing it i just didn't think
anybody would ever hire me because i
thought my talent was just riding a
skateboard